[Musik]
sie warten nicht einmal mehr bis es
dunkel wird die party beginnt sofort
nach feierabend so ausgehungert sind sie
nach monaten des stillhaltens
[Musik]
ich bin so aufgeregt ich muss gleich
weiter tanzen endlich können wir wieder
normale menschen sein
angst habe ich keine der locker und hat
mir angst gemacht
zwei jahre weggesperrt zu sein und man
weiß gar nicht mehr wie das ist normal
in eine bar oder ein restaurant zu gehen
und normal zu essen
es ist das erste wochenende im zeichen
der wiedergewonnenen freiheit masken
runter abstand weg geimpft oder nicht
ist auch erst mal egal und selbst die
krankenschwestern aus der korona station
wollen endlich wieder spaß haben
[Musik]
die arbeit dort hatte einem wirklich das
herz gebrochen das kann man nicht anders
sagen und wenn man das hier sieht
bekommt man erst mal einen schrecken
aber der punkt ist wir müssen irgendwie
weitermachen
ich will das gar nicht beschönigen es
war nicht angenehm aber leute sterben
nun mal jeden tag aus allen möglichen
grund das gehört zu meinem job
ich will jetzt positiv denken das leben
ist einfach kurz das meint auch ihr
oberster boss der gesundheitsminister
selbst infiziert und genießen der den
briten empfahl wir müssen mit cobit
leben lernen und uns nicht davor
wegducken
was doch reichlich zynisch wirkt
angesichts von 130 tausend landsleuten
die eben nicht bitten wird leben konnten
sondern damit starben
der tweet wurde gelöscht die politik
aber bleibt auf kurs
mit vollgas zurück zur normalität aber
dann doch irgendwie mit angezogener
handbremse und die hört sich so an das
gefürchtete warnsignal der korona app
denn wer das fing auf seinem handy hört
der muss zehn tage in selbstisolation
auch bei nur flüchtig im corona kontakt
auch doppelt geimpfte frei testen geht
bisher noch nicht an die 1,7 millionen
angebote so wird geschätzt wurden
bereits aus dem verkehr gezogen
und die fehlen jetzt beim ausliefern der
waren beim einräumen der regale beim
kontrollieren der fahrscheine und sie
fielen im seebad brighton
da wäre nun eigentlich gerade hochsaison
für flaneure sonnenhungrige und
sommerfrischler und das restaurant der
honey sets müsste eigentlich brummen
wir waren ausgebucht das ganze
wochenende freitag samstag sonntag zum
abendessen und dann mussten die die
halbe belegschaft nach hause schicken
und so können wir nicht arbeiten
und anstatt an den 60 tischen drinnen
und auf der terrasse fish chips und
tapas zu kredenzen bietet die wirtin zum
weißen cliff nun um des überlebens
willen der laufkundschaft diverse
eisspezialitäten an und auch ihren
vierbeinigen begleiter statt des grill
tellers mit meeresfrüchten also jetzt
vanilleeis becher fifi mit extra
nährstoffen und natürlich ist nicht nur
ihr personal betroffen
auch die kundschaft wird vom verhassten
ping der wahl app nicht verschont
letzten sonntag hatten wir eine buchung
für einen siebzigsten geburtstag 18
leute und dann riefen sie an und sagten
die hälfte der familie wurde gelingt
und auch hier draußen hat jeder seine
eigene story
es ist sehr frustrierend
bei uns in der firma hatten wir alle
handys auf einem tisch und da fingen sie
schon an zu bringen
so was hatte auch niemand auf dem schirm
und jetzt behalten wir die telefon immer
in der hosentasche und halten zwei meter
abstand um sie nicht scharf zu machen
hat es zweimal aus der schule in
isolation geschickt worden aber sein
kleiner bruder der schule und zimmer mit
ihm teilt musst du das nicht
es ist sehr verwirrend aber wir
versuchen uns trotzdem an die regeln zu
halten wenn man ein lokal besuchten da
war vielleicht stunden vorher einer mit
symptomen
dann wird das auf deine app gemeldet und
schon musst du ihn selbst isolation
wie sich das anfühlt weiß niemand besser
als molly eine der geliebten
servicekräfte aus dem klippen restaurant
es wird langsam echt langweilig hier und
das nervt mich weil ich kein geld
verdienen kann und ich würde auch gerne
wieder ausgehen und meine freunde
treffen dabei hieß es doch der lockdown
sei zu ende aber nun werden alle gepennt
jeder hat seine eigene theorie was
schief gelaufen ist aber eines denken
wohl die meisten sie sind mit corona
noch lange nicht fertig auf der insel
ich glaube die haben einfach zu früh
wieder aufgemacht die wahl app ist zwar
ein ärgernis weil sie zu empfindlich
eingestellt ist meine aber die
eigentlichen probleme kommen denn das
britische impfprogramm das so stark und
effektiv begann ist mittlerweile ins
stocken geraten und nun steigt auch
langsam wieder die zahl der korona
patienten in den krankenhäusern leoni
wurde gerade aus der intensivstation
entlassen er hatte sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen
in den sozialen netzwerken machen sie
einem regelrecht angst vor der impfung
mir auch da sagen sie die nebenwirkungen
wären schlimmer als aber ich weiß es nun
besser
nichts ist schlimmer als
lebensbedrohliches corona
ein kleiner pieks und ein kleines ping
hätten ihm vielleicht viel leid ersparen
können